in terms of being a game changer did it
change the frequency of black cinema you
know what I mean by giving us a
vibration that we had never had like
even watching it tonight a lot of that
stuff still doesn't exist on me but I
want to put this Brandon you haven't
said anything except for it put an
envelope in a toilet LT no no talk talk
to me about your parents but the movies
impact seeing it again tonight well I
think was super cool about Cooley high
in the zeitgeist is that rappers like
common people have referenced this movie
it's been an inspiration for people like
outside of film as well as obviously
hearing things like John Singleton was
influenced and and Spike Lee has always
been super kind and generous about my
dad's work and the influence that have
had on him but just people outside of
actual film referencing Cooley high and
I think there's kind of idea of the
intelligent poet and the the the warrior
poet that's represented in the character
of preach and so it is that idea that
you can be intelligent and still be
strong as a black man that came out of
this movie and those performances that
were given not only by Glenn Thurman but
by the mentor figures that you see in
his life I think about that's super
impactful I think it's lasting people
still dropping it the impact it changed
a whole lot of people's lives it first
of all I can speak on it in terms of
being a professional actress but more so
in terms of being a member of the
Cabrini Green community because we we
got a bum rap as as most African
American communities do we the the press
the way that they that they pictured and
showed who we were in terms of the
violence and the drugs and the
negativity of the area
of course it sold a lot of papers and it
made people turn into the news and
that's the purpose of it but it was lies
what it did was it showed our community
in a way in which we saw our community
yes we did have gangbangers and yes that
we did have Rickon in Norman but we also
had a lot of love we had a lot of
community we had a lot of people who
took care of each other and cared about
each other and the negative part of our
community was very very very small so it
gave us a sense of pride and dignity
that we had never had before and it
changed the whole trajectory of our
community in a way that I can't even
explain except to say it was absolutely
wonderful to see ourselves a man and a
man and a man